es un proyecto de alto riesgo para el
gobierno francés y la primera ministra
Elizabeth lo sabe ha pasado en los
últimos días finalizando el plan de
reforma de pensiones a pesar de las
feroces quejas de los partidos y
sindicatos de la oposición la parte más
Espinosa subir la edad de jubilación de
62 a 64 o incluso 65 años
le dije la primera ministra que si la
edad legal de jubilación se eleva 64 o
65 años la confederación francesa
democrática del trabajo se movilizará en
su contrato
en los planes no está el cambio del
periodo de contribución lo que significa
que para tener derecho a una pensión
completa una persona debe trabajar
durante 43 años antes de la edad legal
de jubilación aquellos que no han
alcanzado esa línea tienen la opción de
trabajar hasta los 67 para obtener una
tarifa completa la pensión mínima sin
embargo aumentará sustancialmente al 85%
del salario mínimo alrededor de 1.200
euros en salario neto los futuros pensio
se beneficiarán de esto pero la primera
ministra aún tiene que anunciar Si los
que ya se jubilaron también lo harán
tras ser presentada este martes la
reforma será enseñada el gabinete el 23
de enero luego será llevada el
parlamento en febrero o marzo el
gobierno espera implementar la reforma a
finales de verano pero con todos los
sindicatos preparándose para
manifestarse en su contra los próximos
meses serán de prueba